i know a lot of you out there are
watching obi-wan miss marvel stranger
things season four the boys and you're
going do i need to see another tv series
i'll tell you what
this one
yes you do
this is one of the best tv series of
2022 thus far and i'm talking about star
trek strange new worlds what's up guys
it's me bobby and we are back talking
about this this series that has really
really shocked me by the way if you're
just joining us here geek culture for
the first time we review movies and tv
shows
tech and gaming all that great stuff so
do check out our other content as well
with that now i'm not paid a response
for this video my thoughts and my
thoughts only but i have absolutely
fallen in love with star trek strange
new world it's awesome it is the dna of
the original series of course it's a
prequel set 10 years before the original
series christopher pike is the captain
before captain kirk takes helm of the
uss enterprise it's a spin-off from star
trek discovery season two when you had
christopher pike una chen riley and
spock were in that they spun it off
filled out the crew put them on the uss
enterprise here for strange new worlds
and they have done a tremendous job this
might be one of the best spin-offs we've
ever seen it is really that good and i
love that it really
pays homage to the original this is the
dna that gene roddenberry this is his
dna this is what he wanted out of star
trek you know discovering new species
and planets and worlds and all those
things and you know trying to make the
universe a better place and trying to
understand different cultures and
different worlds and not just trying to
change them we don't want to do that and
i know a lot of people out there
nowadays are you know in the social
media world are all very aggressive
about you got to think this way and if
you don't you're this or that no this
show just breaks it down to be we are
all accepting and we may disagree we may
agree and it's okay to disagree but we
respect one another and this show brings
that message to the forefront and it's
so desperately needed in 2022 with all
the we're seeing online and
this show does it very very well i'm not
going to spoil this series for you i
want you to discover it yourself the
same way i did i'm going to talk about a
little bit about the cast that is some
of the aspects of the storyline thus far
but let's talk about the visual effects
first the visual effects are some of the
best we're seeing on tv right now the
set design is fantastic they do pay
homage to the original series with the
props and set design but of course they
have could put a spin on to it with
modern technology and newer materials to
make it look really good and really
refreshed and but it looks fantastic uh
i gotta tell you it just they did a
really good job with this i mean and i
watched the behind the scenes it's on
paramount plus by the way so you can
check out those behind the scenes clips
where they talk about uh how they did
the special effects how they're doing
the visual effects and the staging and
all that and even the props how they
took the original props from the
original series and they maul they
modeled the the phaser guns off that and
their communication devices they took it
from that of course they made it a
little bit better as they can you know
so many years after the fact
but there's so much respect for the
original series i mean i was a big fan
of star trek the original series back in
the day then the next generation the
deep space nine and then i kind of just
decided okay there's a lot of star trek
shows out there not i can't keep up with
all of them but then after the
recommendation from a friend of mine to
watch this
i'm back on board baby this is fantastic
all right let's talk about some of the
cast right now anson mount as captain
christopher pike i call him ants in the
hair mount because he's got some hair
that just is up to here man they've got
a lot of hairspray on the uss enterprise
and he's using all of it that's why
spock's hair is flat because it's all
used by uh captain christopher pike but
uh fantastic in the role i love the way
that he portrays uh
pike in this he's got that quick
wittedness he's got that suaveness as a
captain of the uss enterprise needs to
have
um he's very encompassing of his crew he
likes to you know tap on their strengths
he's not a dominating captain he's
authoritative when he needs to be but
he's also accepting of people's
differences but he also tries to make
them grow and you see that in his
portrayal and he does a great job with
that next we've got ethan peck as spock
by the way he's the grandson of gregory
peck for those who know who know and i
love his portrayal of spock this is my
second favorite outside of leonard nimoy
the og the best of the best
of course he's always trying to figure
out this you know the battle that
difference between his human side and
his vulcan side and i love how ethan
portrays it it's refreshing it's a
little bit different
and he does a great job with it i don't
want to give too much away but it is a
different take on spock but at the same
time it's the dna of spock but i really
like how he portrays the character next
we've got celia rose gooding who plays
noto uhura that's right cadet uhura in
the strange new worlds of course who
becomes uhura as we know in
the main the original series right
played by michelle nichols
this is a very different take of uhura
as we've seen from the original series i
like it it's different and celia does a
great job with this she is
a rookie on the uss enterprise so she
doesn't have an integral role in this
show she has there's a couple episodes
where she's the focus and others she's
just there for a brief moment but that's
like every character on star trek you
know there's moments they shine there's
moments they don't but every character
has a journey and the writers do a great
job and making every moment those
characters are on screen count and they
did a great job with her and she's great
in the role next we've got babs i'm
going to say his name incorrectly ooh
as dr embanka chief medical officer of
the uss enterprise he's one of my
favorite characters this guy's a
fantastic actor so much gravitas so much
i mean when he when he comes on screen
at the presence this man has
holy he's got a great storyline it
is heartbreaking it's heartwarming it's
gonna make you smile it's gonna make you
sad it is beautiful and how he portrays
it the emotion in this man's eyes i mean
he's a fantastic actor and he knocks it
out of the park with this
next we got rebecca romain who plays una
chin riley the number one to christopher
pike on the uss enterprise rebecca
remains uh formerly stamos who played
mystique and x-men
the same one and we know mystique back
in x-men back in the day
oh yeah
uh and she's cool i didn't recognize her
from the beginning of the show because
her hair is dyed dark brown
and a very different persona in this
she's very good as the number one and i
don't want to give too much away of her
character but very interesting thus far
and i'm looking to see what they do with
their character
they've shown some interesting sides to
her but more is going to come we're only
in six episodes thus far at the time of
this recording and is up to 10 this
season and season 2 coming in 2023 so
looking forward to seeing where they're
taking that character next we've got
christina chong who plays la'an nunyen
singh and if you recognize that name
nunian singh that is khan noonian singh
she is a descendant of khan
but she's the chief of security on the
uss enterprise but she is a good person
she's not like khan she's a good person
and i like what christina's doing with
the character um very focused very
serious thus far she's all about her job
she wants to be the best security
officer the uss enterprise has ever seen
or at least that's how they betray her
to be
but she has some very interesting
moments in the series thus far
especially with spock i don't want to
give too much away but there are some
really great moments with her character
and i'm excited to see where they take
her next we got jess bush who plays
christine chapel and uh she is a medical
officer in sick bay and christine chapel
we did see in the original series
briefly jess bush has kind of taken this
role into her own right and uh she's one
of the standouts man a lot of people are
liking her i mean she's pretty easy on
the eyes guys just is a beautiful woman
great actress as well and a lot of
people are liking what they're doing
with her character and uh interesting i
don't want to say too much but there's
some interesting things and i'm seeing
some sparks fly with another integral
character on the uss enterprise i don't
want to say who but it's not pike it's
not pike it's somebody else you might
not expect anyone let's see how that
unfolds as the series progresses
next we've got melissa nabia who plays
eric ortegas the enterprises helmsman
and um so far her character there are
diving into some aspects of her
character
i don't want to give too much away on
this um but
she's a pretty good pilot
knows how to shoot some photon torpedoes
out there pretty badass in many ways i'm
excited to see where they take her
character we haven't seen that much of
her in terms of character development
thus far up to episode six there has
been some minor development but uh she's
fun to watch and she's really good at
the role so looking forward to see what
she does with it
and last but not least i mean there's a
lot of characters in this show but i'm
just kind of talking about the top line
ones here bruce horak who plays hammer
the enterprise's chief engineer
he is an anar who is an albino
subspecies of the andorians um i'm not
too familiar with that uh
species but some of you out there may
know them more though so than i his
character does look familiar for what
i've seen from previous star trek uh
episodes out there but um yeah he's very
cool very serious very focused on being
chief engineer this guy doesn't mess
around and don't mess around with his uh
his area of the uss enterprise because
he will get very upset he takes his job
seriously but there's some nice growth
to his character that we're seeing thus
far but he hasn't been
in all the episodes from what i uh i
remember but he's in a lot of them but
i'm excited to see where they take him
because he's very cool and i like what
they're doing with them anyway those are
some of the main characters of the uss
enterprise thus far there's a lot of
other others out there and what i love
about the series as i mentioned
is that pike brings all these characters
together and he focuses on their
strengths he helps build them up and i
like how this series is very
intelligently written it is um it
doesn't dumb anything down and i like
how
they are trying to reshape star trek in
a way that is very much as i said the
essence of roddenberry's you know
original series out there
and uh you know it's kind of bringing it
back to the basics and i kind of like
that they're doing that because that was
a star trek i fell in love with and i
think a lot of you have as well and
that's why i think star trek strange new
world is one of the best tv series on
right now this is one of my favorite
shows thus far 2022 let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below is
this a series you're looking to check
out have you seen it do you disagree
with me do you agree with me who is your
favorite character in strange new worlds
love to hear from you with that like
always follow us on facebook subscribe
to us on youtube be safe out there and
i'll chat to you soon take care
[Music]
you